would you rather fight a short gladiator
or a rhino
i'm gonna go short gladiator because i
don't even have to fight him i can just
make five three jokes all day like
what's up dude what's it like not being
able to reach the brown sugar on the top
shelf and then he just puts his armor
down he's like you know what man [ __ ]
you and then he turned into the bagel
boss guy remember actually bagel boss
guy was very angry i might go back to
rhino okay i'm nervous short people do
have that short people energy where
they'll swing but they'll hit you in the
kneecap but it's like it's like a stiff
one so you just hit your leg on the on
the tabletop
but yeah i'm going short people because
rhinos
i don't know rhinos are too intimidating
because that's the number one animal
they put on like sex like boner pills so
there's just a lot to comprehend there
when it's like running at you and you're
like god this reminds me of an erection
then everybody's like what did you just
say and you're like bring out the
gladiators just bring them out